voyons maintenant une nouvelle mode du
prêt-à-porter qui tient salon en ce
moment à la porte de versailles à paris
le streetwear la mode de la rue en
français elle vient des banlieues
c'était un phénomène masculin qui est en
train de conquérir les jeunes femmes
elisabeth aisée parce quelqu'un comme la
haute couture elle à son salon ses
collections ses défilés
apparu au fond s'il ya dix ans la mode
streetwear a quitté les banlieues mais
beaucoup de jeunes créateurs y ont
grandi
serge vient de marseille il y a cinq ans
il a créé sa petite entreprise avec un
associé de 83 ans aujourd'hui
sa marque est connue on a démarré on
était trois on est resté 3 pendant deux
ans et demi en moyenne depuis le début
en fait entre 60 et 70% selon les années
de progression
à l'origine le streetwear n'était porté
que par les 15 25 ans aujourd'hui ils
ont grandi les créateurs doivent suivre
en élargissant leurs gammes pour plaire
à des clients - je ne renie pas leur
passé avec les logos avec tout ce qu'ils
ont créé mais aujourd'hui on met des
vestes on en est on est habillé on
mélange à la fois cet esprit urbain et
ce côté habillé et puis on fait tout
pour attirer les filles très masculine
cette mode tente de se féminiser pour
attirer une clientèle potentielle
sûrement énorme
les créateurs veulent que les femmes
hésitent de moins en moins à porter des
baskets avec un tailleur l'enjeu
commercial est de taille